[Aplausos]
[Música]
seamos honestos un año después de la
irrupción de lakovic 19 todos nos hemos
convertido aunque sólo sea un poquito en
expertos en pandemias a ver quién se
atreva a decirme por ejemplo que nunca
ha discutido sobre esta o aquella vacuna
sobre las pr de los tests de antígenos o
el origen del virus me apuesto a que
ninguno sin embargo aunque nos parezca
que ya no sabemos el nombre y apellido
de todas las vacunas habidas y por haber
estoy seguro de que en esta ocasión
vamos a descubrir algo nuevo a ver
decidme habéis oído hablar alguna vez de
la vacuna uzbeko china me la juego a que
no amigos hablamos de una vacuna que se
ha registrado en un pakistán bajo el
nombre zf ez v ac 2001 como para
recordarlo pero no os preocupéis porque
en este vídeo no nos vamos a meter en
bioquímica lo que me interesa es que nos
fijemos en esa curiosa relación china y
uzbekistán porque decidieron producir
juntos esta vacuna que es exactamente lo
que une a estos dos países en este vídeo
tenemos mucho de que hablar y no solo lo
haremos de uzbekistán
porque queridos amigos amigas de visual
político en el mapamundi hay una región
en la que todos decidieron ponerle a sus
países el mismo sufijo hablamos de
kazajistán uzbekistán kirguistán
tayikistán y türkmenistán o en otras
palabras hacia central
hablamos de una región que estuvo en el
punto de mira de las grandes potencias
desde el siglo 19 y lo cierto es que la
actualidad la situación no ha cambiado
mucho hoy la competición por la
influencia se disputa entre rusia eeuu
turquía la india pakistán y por supuesto
china pekín amigos lleva años
invirtiendo los instantes construye
infraestructuras se envía a su mano de
obra y controla porcentajes altísimos de
la duda externa de estos países y eso
eso es precisamente lo que vamos a ver
que está haciendo china en asia central
quien sale ganando se está acaso
convirtiendo esta región del mundo en el
nuevo campo de expansión del recobrado
imperio chino arranquemos
[Música]
un matrimonio marrón ático
como quizás ya está sospechando en este
vídeo vamos a hablar mucho de dinero y
es que aquí encontramos una de las
fronteras más desiguales del mundo por
ejemplo a ninguno sorprenderá así os
digo que el pib de china es 50 veces más
grande que el de todos los países de
asia central juntos vamos que comparar
la china como por ejemplo tayikistán es
como hablar de david y goliat claro que
en este caso david y goliat no se pelean
sino que comercia lo que por otra parte
pues nos resulta extraño al fin y al
cabo hablamos de países vecinos y lo
raro sería que no tuvieran ninguna
relación comercial pues lo cierto amigos
es que china es también uno de los
principales inversores de acreedores de
la región y de todos lo que más le
interesa es el sector energético una
empresa china construir una planta
hidroeléctrica en kazajistán eximbank
chino asignó un préstamo un banco para
modernizar centrales hidroeléctricas y
eso no es todo lo veremos luego pero ya
os adelanto que varias rutas de la nueva
ruta de la seda pasan precisamente por
asia central por eso pekín también está
construyendo y financiando las
infraestructuras de transporte como
carreteras y ferrocarriles que necesitan
para garantizar el tránsito de sus
productos eso sí recordad que hablamos
de países entre poco y nada democráticos
en los que gobierna simple y llanamente
con un poder absoluto
así que muchas veces pues el dinero se
evapora de las propias estadísticas
oficiales por eso las inversiones
extranjeras son una apuesta arriesgada
en esta región e incluso china ya se ha
quemado más de una vez
así que últimamente se dedica a
proyectos un poquito más pequeños a
algunas fábricas y plantas de cemento o
minas de oro cobre zinc y otros recursos
naturales
por otro lado pekín también está
financiando en estos países la
construcción de escuelas y facultades en
las que se estudia chino está abriendo
institutos confucio por toda la región e
incluso tiene en marcha un montón de
programas de becas para que los
estudiantes centros éticos puedan hacer
intercambios académicos en china todo un
ejemplo de expansión del poder blando la
nueva realidad de la influencia china
que en occidente aún desconocemos pero
que cada vez tiene más peso
en total en los últimos 15 años china ha
destinado 54 mil millones de dólares a
las inversiones y la construcción en
asia central es decir más o menos lo
mismo que todo el pib de uzbekistán pero
amigos pueden que estas alturas estéis
pensando que la relación díaz es central
con china solo está marcada por el
dinero pues lo cierto es que tienen algo
más en común su pasión por la tecnología
y el control
y decirme qué nombre le darías a un
proyecto que consiste en la vigilancia
constante y el reconocimiento facial
pues al mejor estilo orweliano se llama
ciudades seguras y no sé si os gusta la
idea pero os puedo decir a quien le
encanta tayikistán yo que existan están
ya desarrollando sus programas de
ciudades seguras de la mano de huawei y
por supuesto en el concepto de seguridad
se tiene sobretodo en cuenta la
seguridad de los gerifaltes que ocupan
el poder y siguiendo con tayikistán no
podemos olvidarnos de un aspecto más en
sus relaciones con china hablamos de la
presencia militar de un recién llegado
silencioso en las montañas de asia
central las tropas chinas ya sabéis que
china tiene bases militares en yibutí en
el mar del sur de china pero amigos la
de tayikistán es su primera aparición en
asia central y tiene que ver con la
seguridad de la frontera afgana fijaos
por ejemplo en este mapa estáis viendo
la triple frontera entre china
tayikistán y afganistán en el corredor
de wakhan la primera base militar china
en asia central está situada
precisamente en el territorio técnico
muy cerca de este punto puede que nos
parezca algo tan importante pero para
china es todo un hito y un salto de
gigante hasta ahora a sus relaciones con
la región se limitaban a la parte
económica pero el peso de china está
creciendo y ahora quiere alcanzar un
nuevo
roll incluso durante los últimos meses
pekín no ha dejado escapar la
oportunidad de afianzar su influencia en
esta región con un nuevo tipo de
diplomacia la de las vacunas si
recordáis empezamos este vídeo hablando
de la vacuna uzbeko china que ha sido
desarrollada por la biofarmacéutica and
with you' fei long com y por la academia
china de las ciencias y me diréis a ver
si las dos instituciones son chinas qué
diablos pinta yo sé que estar pues
amigos aquí empieza lo interesante de
christan fue uno de los países que
participó en los ensayos de esta vacuna
también lo han hecho por ejemplo ecuador
y panista pero en febrero del 2021
ocurrió esto la empresa china reconoció
uzbekistán como coautor en el desarrollo
de la vacuna zf 2001
uzbekistán se convirtió oficialmente en
el coautor de la vacuna gracias citó a
su contribución y esfuerzo no sabemos si
es que para que está en ecuador pues no
se esforzaron lo suficiente pero lo
cierto es que la siguiente noticia tardó
menos de dos semanas en ver la luz
uzbekistán a prueba la vacuna para la
cob y 19 desarrollada por china fue el
primer país de esa central en hacerlo y
de esta forma abrió las puertas de la
región a las vacunas de china poco
después que registrar y türkmenistán
aprobaron la sino farc y tayikistán está
a la espera de recibir sus y novak en
asia central amigos cada vez más todo
gira en torno a china
y todo esto al final para que porque a
china le interesa tanto asia central y
viceversa que ganan los instantes con el
gigante asiático atento
ah
la letra pequeña
si sois seguidores asiduos de visual
político pues no hace falta recordaros
que la política exterior china de hoy no
tiene nada que ver con lo que era hace
50 años es lo que tiene ser un país con
una economía mucho más grande y próspera
pues bien en lo que se refiere a asia
central china empezó a ganar
protagonismo en la década de los 90
recordad que hasta en 1991 los instantes
eran parte de la unión soviética y en
esta última etapa las relaciones chinos
soviéticas dejaban mucho que desear así
que a partir de esta fecha
pekín ha tenido que resolver los
problemas más tribales con sus nuevos
vecinos a ver cómo delimitamos las
fronteras o qué hacemos frente a la
guerra civil en tayikistán pero el
principal cambio se dio en los años 2000
cuando china se lanzó a invertir por el
mundo la enorme cantidad de dólares que
estaba acumulando gracias a su enorme
superávit comercial
pero y porque exactamente esa central
pues fundamentalmente por tres razones
fijaos
por una parte china comparte más de tres
mil kilómetros de frontera con
kazajistán kirguistán y tayikistán y
además tiene mucho en común con los
países de la región por ejemplo a
comienzos de los 90 uno de cada mil
habitantes de china era kazajo tayika
uzbeka y kirguís por otra parte desde
1993 china consume más energía de la que
produce es decir necesite importarla así
que los instantes se han convertido para
pekín en una fuente crucial de petróleo
y gas y en tercer lugar en 2013 china
anunció la creación de la nueva ruta de
la seda por eso asia central se
convirtió en un espacio clave de su
parte terrestre para conectar los
productos chinos con los mercados
europeos
pero como creo que esto más o menos lo
tenemos claro pasemos si os parece a la
siguiente pregunta que gana exactamente
hacia central en su relación con china
[Música]
pues veréis aquí hay que tener en cuenta
que tras la caída de la unión soviética
los instantes se convirtieron en los
países más pobres de todo el espacio
postsoviético durante décadas tuvieron
unos sistemas de producción muy
interconectados entre sí y eran
básicamente economías de monocultivo es
decir estaban muy especializadas en unos
pocos productos que producían a gran
escala para abastecer luego al resto de
repúblicas pero cuando se terminó la
unión soviética todo eso se vino abajo
claro que hubo un momento porque ojalá
todos los problemas de esta región
fueran económicos pero no porque es algo
que existan en el plano político son un
ejemplo de no democratización
hablamos amigos de regímenes muy
personalistas que no tienen ningún
interés por los derechos humanos sumarle
a eso la corrupción endémica y ya tenéis
el retrato de una región en la que muy
pocos quieren invertir precisamente por
eso los créditos de china fueron algo
así como el maná caído del cielo además
el dinero de pekín no está condicionado
a reformas políticas ni nada por el
estilo y por si fuera poco al
desarrollar gracias al dinero chino
nuevas carreteras y gasoductos hacia el
este los instantes están reduciendo su
dependencia histórica de rusia así que
hasta aquí podría parecernos una
relación casi perfecta pero acordaos de
que siempre siempre hay que leer la
letra pequeña y es que en sus relaciones
con la central china es la que dicta las
condiciones
[Música]
por eso muchos contratos implican el uso
de maquinaria china el empleo de mano de
obra china y la resolución de posibles
controversias ante tribunales chinos y
por supuesto hablamos de china que no es
un país que juegue precisamente a ser el
más popular de la clase empezando por
las condiciones laborales que suelen ser
francamente malas así que no penséis que
está siendo coser y cantar en los dos
últimos años tan solo los dos últimos
años la región ha visto más de 40
manifestaciones en contra de la
expansión china y en ocasiones han
tenido consecuencias directas con un
proyecto de 280 millones de dólares
liderado por tim en kirguistán es
abandonado después de las protestas en
cualquier caso con carácter general los
sentimientos anti chinos han crecido más
en kazajistán y crystal países en los
que un tercio de la población tiene una
opinión negativa sobre el gigante
asiático por el contrario china está
mucho mejor vista en los dos países con
los que no hace frontera
'tuve quixtán y türkmenistán claro que
en esta región del mundo la opinión
pública pues no representa ni mucho
menos las posturas oficiales y si china
tiene el ganado esos son precisamente
los corazones de las élites dados cuenta
de que la falta de transparencia es una
gran aliada de la corrupción a menudo no
hay forma de saber cuánto dinero se va
afuera por el camino sin dejar
en otras palabras que los enormes
créditos de china le vienen muy bien a
los gerifaltes políticos de asia central
para cobrar su margen su intermediación
y eso es una de las cosas que provoca
que muchas veces pues estos proyectos no
tengan luego el rendimiento esperado y
claro qué pasa cuando toca devolver los
préstamos
china no perdona las deudas
amigos en economía la deuda externa son
todas aquellas obligaciones que un país
tiene con otros países o con
instituciones extranjeras por ejemplo
los créditos que ofrece el eximbank
chino se traducen en deuda externa para
los países que reciben estos créditos y
ya os podéis imaginar que ningún país de
asia central está exento de la deuda con
china pekín controla el 42 por ciento de
la deuda externa que guisa el 40 por
ciento de la tallec a el 20% de los
beckham y el 10% de la kazaja luego
sobre türkmenistán no os podemos ofrecer
ningún dato porque las estadísticas
publicadas pues no son el fuerte de su
régimen lo que está claro es que los
países más endeudados son también los
dos más pobres de la región kirguistán y
tayikistán y os preguntaréis por qué
china le presta tanto dinero a países
que quizás luego no puedan devolverlo
pues en el mundo de las relaciones
internacionales hay teorías para todos
hace cuatro años el académico obras
marché la cne y presentó la suya que se
llama la diplomacia de la trampa de la
deuda
en resumen viene a decir que china no
espera recuperar los préstamos que
ofrece a países poco desarrollados en
vez de esto pretende crear un vínculo de
dependencia política e incluso desafiar
la soberanía de estos estados
claro que esto es sólo una teoría desde
luego ni chinas el [ __ ] ni asia
central ni ningún otro país del mundo
está obligado a aceptar sus créditos
aplica sin más la teoría de la
diplomacia de la trampa de la deuda
implicaría eximida a las élites locales
de toda responsabilidad y no sé quizás
el problema sea precisamente el
incentivo perverso que genera la
corrupción algo así como yo medio y
parte y ya veremos como el estado luego
paga la suya el caso amigos es que cada
país está buscando sus formas de hacer
frente a la cada vez mayor de una china
por ejemplo o türkmenistán le está
vendiendo delgadas por debajo del precio
del mercado kazajistán que hace frontera
con la región china de xinjiang está
manteniendo un perfil bajo frente a la
persecución de los seguros pero quizás
los casos más interesantes sean los de
tayikistán y kirguistán y es que para
estos dos países una de las formas más
habituales de devolver la deuda china es
cediendo los derechos de explotación de
recursos naturales por eso nos podemos
encontrar noticias como ésta
tayikistán ratifica la transferencia de
minas de oro a china a día de hoy hasta
el 80% de las minas de oro de tayikistán
están bajo el control precisamente de
empresas chinas y no sólo se trata de
eso porque hay rumores de que la
reticencia de tayikistán a entrar en la
unión económica euroasiática de la que
por cierto yo os hablamos en un vídeo
en la descripción se explica
precisamente por los intereses de pekín
y luego la guinda del pastel en el año
2011 el parlamento tayiko ratificó un
nuevo protocolo sobre la delimitación de
las fronteras por el que china recibía
ni más ni menos que mil kilómetros
cuadrados en el sistema montañoso de
familia es decir casi en uno por ciento
de todo el territorio de tayikistán
amigos china no perdona sus deudas
[Aplausos]
la situación de kirguistán es aún peor
al igual que el resto de los países de
asia central su economía depende
fuertemente de las remesas que suponen
más del 30 por ciento del pib
por eso la pandemia del coronavirus
supuso un golpe durísimo para este país
y ahora lo tiene todavía más difícil
para solventar su deuda con china que
también supone en torno a un 30 por
ciento de su pib
seguro seguro que no vais a acertar cuál
fue la propuesta oficial para hacer
frente a esta deuda preparados pues aquí
la tenéis se abre una cuenta para la
transferencia de fondos para pagar la
deuda este ranking es tan habéis oído
bien el ministerio de finanzas aquí lis
ha abierto una cuenta bancaria para que
cualquier persona pues pueda sufragar la
ayuda externa del país y lo más fuerte
es que no es la primera vez que ocurre
en 2007 el entonces presidente a tan
bayern también abría una cuenta bancaria
igual para que os hagáis una idea
entonces la deuda externa era de mil 991
millones de dólares ahora bien cuánto
dinero creéis que recaudó pues
evidentemente poco ni más ni menos que
tres mil 350 dólares en 2020 les ha ido
un poco mejor sí pero estamos hablando
de unos 12 mil dólares que por supuesto
pues no es nada en comparación con la
deuda externa de kirguistán así que de
momento con remedios como éste pues el
país no tiene más camino que seguir
ahondando su dependencia con china y
ahora ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
qué os parece esta idea del crowdfunding
con lo fiáis el papel de china sea
central se pueden aprovechar los
créditos de china sin caer en la
dependencia podéis dejarnos por aquí
abajo vuestras respuestas y altas sabéis
si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros a visual político una vez
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo
[Música]